Kim Kardashian seeking punishment for  the man who has now targeted her twice  on Wednesday Kim was nearly attacked by  this man in Paris before bodyguards  tackled him to the ground the attacker  is notorious prankster Vitaly see do the  same person who manhandled Gigi Hadid  after a fashion show just last week  Bradley Cooper Leonardo DiCaprio and  America Ferrera have all been targeted  he even rushed the Grammy stage during  Adele speech on wednesday's attack see  Duke offered this explanation via  Instagram his attempt to kiss Kim's  backside was a protest against quote Kim  for using fake butt implants the  implants claim is something Kim has  denied in the past and for her part  she's reportedly filing a complaint  against see Duke with Paris police this  is the second time in two years as see  Duke has gotten this close to Kim you  call it a sprang sticker I don't be like  this world but I'm entertaining reporter